the New Year inspires many Americans to
reflect on their health last year we saw
the rise of a mysterious polio like
illness affecting children around the
country and the work of a Chinese
scientist led to ethical questions about
gene editing meanwhile medical
breakthroughs like 3d body-part printing
and health devices you can wear show the
increasing power of technology in our
healthcare dr. tara nurullah joins us
for a look at the medical stories that
could affect us in 2019 Tara happy New
Year to you happy New Year to you let's
start with AFM which which stands for
acute flaccid mile Lotus my myelitis how
do you say it my lightest myelitis so
what do we know about it at this point
what's being done to stop it it was very
scary very scary disease very scary for
parents because it mostly affects
children and so what we know is that we
see spikes in these cases every two
years or so and it really started around
2014 that we began really tracking this
but the reality is I want to keep it in
perspective that it is very rare so
we're talking about one or two children
out of a million that will be affected
per year since 2014 about 491 cases we
think it may be caused by a virus we
don't know which one and that the virus
affects the motor neurons in the spinal
cord it may cause an inflammatory
reaction and certain kids may just be
genetically susceptible and what happens
is the child may start out with a mild
respiratory like infection and then it
progresses to weakness in the arms or
legs trouble with vision swallowing or
speaking so it can be very scary in
certain instances kids can recover but
other times they have progressive or
worsening paralysis that remains for a
long time or even respiratory failure
the cdc assembled a task force in
november and really are working very
hard to kind of get a handle on this and
we also know that technology continues
to play a vital role in healthcare and
the idea of 3d printing body organs is
something we're going to hear a lot more
about tell us about it it's really
fascinating and so you think you can 3d
print a toy or replace a heart why not
an organ and so for example we would
take an MRI of your heart create a
scaffold structure of exactly what your
heart viana looks like and then the ink
would be may a mixture of cells and
biodegradable materials essentially
printed with that scaffolding that's
scaffolding then degrades over time and
you're left with
three D heart and so the idea is that
this is really perfectly suited for your
body because it came from imaging of you
and it will prevent rejection because
it's made from your own cells the incus
and so we think we're about five to ten
years away from really having this
implanted in people and we think a
bladder may be the first organ that
we're able to do but we already are
implanting things that are artificial
hips and replacement parts artificial
sense for the airways so we're getting
closer a lot more work than it needs to
be done what does this mean for
longevity because I'm thinking
replacement parts well it's really with
organ the organ donor issue you know we
know that a hundred thousand people are
waiting for organs every year and
there's only 16,000 donors so the idea
is that this can really be a wonderful
thing for that for several years
scientists have been talking about the
technology known as CRISPR which is gene
editing and then just at the end of 2018
Chinese doctor claimed to have used it
successfully this is the future of
medicine being able to edit our bad
genes out does it work and he got
hammered you or one of the people very
upset about a lot of people in the
community were outraged
so CRISPR is a really fascinating
technology it's like a scissor that can
go in and essentially edit your DNA it
has a lot of potential and right now
we're using it mostly in cells and
animal models to explore treating
diseases that can be devastating things
like cystic fibrosis Tay Sachs
Huntington's sickle-cell it has a lot of
promise in the future for things like
heart disease and mental health and
cancer even but the problem with what
happened this last month is that it was
used to alter embryos and when you're
doing that and the technology is still
premature you're risking creating other
mutations in those embryos those
children can go on to have
susceptibilities to other problems down
the roads or other infections and now
you're altering the genetic code for
every child that that child has so it
really needs to be done when the
technology is ready and right now the
scientific scientific community saying
we're not there yet
so I think what the controversy has done
is really raised a lot of red flags and
a lot of people are gonna be on guard
and watching to put up better guidelines
about how we use Chris we're going
forward we haven't heard from that
doctor as of late I heard Terra thank
you happy new year you
year looking forward to a lot more
stories from you this year thank you